[Music]
Jeremiah was a bullfrog was a good
friend of mine all throughout season
five we get so many little nods to the
60s and we get to really see them
incorporate it into their day-to-day
life especially with a lot of musical
moments what was it like for you guys
getting to have those kind of sixties
moments in whatever you guys are
currently yeah yeah especially for Roger
Brianne clay you know they have to
monitor so many aspects of the
personality their language and
everything when they're around other
people they're references so it's lovely
when we do get those scenes where we can
let the 60s seep in and the three of
them are just together and they can talk
so candidly and even have those
nostalgic moments yeah I get to hold off
for throwing in okay's for Brianna
because I'm like you couldn't monitor
yourself a hundred percent of the time I
mean she's not an actress so especially
when she gets angry I like to try and
get as much 60s language in there as I
can but I do get told off when it comes
to the stones we have two different
teams on Fraser's Ridge we have Roger
and Claire who think that you guys
should go back and we have Bree and
Jamie who are keen to stay at Frazier's
Ridge what do you think they should do
that seems to be the way you put that
that feels to me like very much logic
versus emotion tremendous there does the
logic practicality of what that you we
should go at safer which is a large part
of it absolutely but then you have what
when is the heart where is the feeling
well I think one thing we keep saying as
well is that actually you know even if
Audra and Brianna decided together made
a unanimous decision to go back to the
future they don't know where they're
going back to they could walk into World
War 3 so if we're talking about just the
safety of the future or the 1700s you
can't really weigh those up equally and
they reference that you know the Vietnam
War was going on in the left so you
never know where that's up to you know
and in terms of safety for Jamie Roger
and Bree have a conversation of okay yes
the 1700's is brutal for a child in
terms of you know you've got no
pacifiers no diapers no babies safety
gates or whatever you know Jamie could
just open a door and stop playing with a
knife like it's it's tough but then in
the 70s you have cars and you have road
safety and you have all those aspects so
even though there are you know so many
emotions that come into play in the
decision the logic isn't as logical as
it might seem to be but for Brianna
definitely I mean she I always say even
in the 60s she went from having two
parents - one two three - nan and you
know she did essentially often herself
and now she has this whole family around
her Jamie and Claire have now become
grandparents so - tad jammy away from
his grandparents to tear the family
apart is just a huge decision but
obviously she knows that Raj is
struggling in that time and that factors
into so it's definitely a through-line
for season five yeah so who knows you
want to go back don't you our family is
here you are my family
well speaking of struggles they're both
growing through individual struggles
let's talk a little bit about Roger he's
been made the captain of Jamie's militia
congratulations congratulations yes you
seem both terrified and thrilled yes
yeah how far is he willing to go to find
his place in this family and also please
his father-in-law I think Roger will go
to any lengths the foe has ruled to find
the right rule to find his place and
fulfill and I think you'd do anything
for his family and I could do it to
provide for his family I think he'll do
anything to keep them safe and I think
he's very much a very well participant
and that has weighed our family clear
and Jamie I think you start to really
become part of the freezer family also
when I think it's so obviously about
overwhelm it's about daunting the fact
that he's been annoying to the captain
of Jamie's militia he has no military
experience he's not a captain he'll have
knowledge of military history but that's
about
yeah but it throws himself into it and
he wants to prove himself and you know
very much has to think on his feet and
provide and come up with solutions to
things which he would never have
imagined having to come up with
solutions for like chem episode - link
yes brother but I think you can only
have said that very quickly but I think
he's very very determined very willing
to do that there's something I must tell
Stephan Bonnar DISA life you do see that
Bree is struggling with the news that
bonnet escaped the fire like the
cockroach that he is take me into her
mindset she's trying to deal with this
as she's being super paranoid but I
think rightfully so that the potential
father of her child is out there lurking
I think initially for Bree she has
whether she fully believed it or not
she's found some peace in thinking that
bonnet died in the fire one thing I
really did want to make sure that we did
bring into the season was Briana's PTSD
you know it has been a time pass since
season four in season five but it's you
know not something that you just get
over overnight and you know for Brianna
and for me as an actress I'm aware that
you know it's the first episode of the
season it's the wedding it needs to be
happy and light and everything else and
obviously you know brie is ecstatic to
be getting married but there are still
those demons in there for her but as
ever with brie she's very good at
putting on that facade of being okay and
holding her her strength together for
her family
so yes it is you know overseen the first
episode we get to see what Brees
actually feeling and that is heightened
by her sort of worst fears being
confirmed that bonnet is alive and I
think from her knowing from season four
from her meeting with bonnet when bonnet
gives her the gem her knowing that
bonnet therefore might actually have an
interest in Germany and an interest in
wanting to meet Jamie and being the
father I think in knowing that he's
alive it then does raise that fear of is
he going to you know come back for Jami
really hurt Jeremy will he take Jamie
once what's going to happen so for brie
it makes her even more jumpy than she
was already
[Music]